PORTLAND IS NOT A PROTEST BUT
"ASSAULT ON THE GOVERNMENT OF
THE UNITED STATES."
HERE WITH REACTION, SENATE
JUDICIARY’S CHAIRMAN
LINDSEY GRAHAM.
THE SUB SOURCE WAS INTERVIEWED
THREE DAYS IN JANUARY OF 2017.
AM I CORRECT ON THAT?
>> THAT’S RIGHT AND ACTUALLY
AGAIN IN MARCH.
TWO OR THREE SEPARATE OCCASIONS.
THREE DAYS IN JANUARY AND AGAIN
IN MARCH OF 2017.
>> Sean: OKAY, SO THE SUB
SOURCE.
THIS WAS A GUY WHO SAID THIS WAS
BARTOK AND MRS. -- DIDN’T DO
MUELLER REPORT SAY, WEREN’T WE
TOLD THAT THIS INFORMATION HAD R
THEY DIDN’T.
>> I DON’T KNOW ABOUT YOU BUT I
ALWAYS ASSUME THE RUSSIAN SUB
SOURCE WAS SOME GUY IN RUSSIA
DEEP IN THE OF THE KREMLIN.
FEEDING THE STUFF TO
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
THE SUB SOURCE WAS A SENIOR
RUSSIAN RESEARCHER AT THE
BROOKINGS INSTITUTE AN EMPLOYEE
OF CHRISTOPHER STEELE LIVING IN
THE UNITED STATES.
HE CALLS UP A BUNCH OF PEOPLE IN
RUSSIA.
WOULD YOU THINK THIS INFORMATION
CAME FROM?
IT CAME FROM THE RUSSIAN
INTELLIGENCE SERVICE.
THEY PLAYED THE SKY LIKE A
FETTLE.
THIS IS RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION.
SOME FBI RECOGNIZED IT AS SUCH.
HE TOLD STEELE, HERE’S WHAT I
FOUND BUT IT’S NOT REALLY
RELIABLE BECAUSE STEELE TURNED
IT INTO A TOM CLANCY NOVEL.
THE FBI BOUGHT IT HOOK, LINE,
AND SINKER AND GOT WARRANTS.
THE MOST SUCCESSFUL POLITICAL
OPERATION THE HISTORY OF
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THAT STEELE
WAS ON THE PAYROLL OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND
HILLARY CLINTON’S CAMPAIGN.
>> Sean: WE WERE LEARNED ON
THE UNCLASSIFIED DOCUMENT FROM
LAST WEEK FROM YOU, WHAT DID WE
LEARN?
WE LEARNED THAT WHEN THEY WENT
TO BRIEF THE PRESIDENT AND THE
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR ELECT
IF IT WOULD BE IF THEY GOT
ELECTED GENERAL FLYNN.
THAT WAS A RUSE FOR OPERATION
CROSSFIRE HURRICANE.
WE KNOW THEY KNEW FROM BEFORE
THE FIRST DIRTY DOSSIER THAT IT
WAS UNVERIFIED.
STEELE HAD AN AGENDA AND CLINTON
PAID FOR IT AND THEY SAID IT WAS
VERIFIED.
IT’S UNVERIFIABLE.
IT’S BEEN DEBUNKED.
THEY STILL SIGN THOSE AND THEN
EVEN AFTER THE SUB SOURCE, IN
OTHER WORDS CHRISTOPHER STEELE’S
SOURCES, THEN THEY WENT ON TO
SIGN TWO MORE WARRANTS.
HOW IS THAT NONPREMEDITATED
FRAUD ON A FISA COURT AND WHAT
HAS TAKEN JOHN DURHAM SO LONG TO
GET THAT FUNDAMENTAL CONCLUSION?
WHAT WE NOW KNOW IS
OVERWHELMING, INCONTROVERTIBLE
SLAM-DUNK.
THAT NEEDS TO BE BROUGHT BEFORE
A GRAND JURY, LINDSEY GRAHAM.
WHEN IS THAT GOING TO HAPPEN?
>> I DON’T KNOW.
WE WILL FIND OUT SOON I SUPPOSE.
I’M GOING TO INTERVALE THE INTEL
ANALYST WHO INTERVIEWED THE
RUSSIAN SUB SOURCE AND PRODUCE
THE 40 PAGE
MEMO AND NOBODY ELSE WILL
TALK TO HIM, I’M GOING TO
TALK TO HIM IN THE CASE AGENT
AND ASKED HIM AS A POLL
QUESTION.
WHEN HE FOUND OUT THAT THE
RUSSIAN SUB SOURCE WAS A STEELE
EMPLOYEE NOT BASED IN RUSSIA BUT
BASED IN THE UNITED STATES, AND
EVERYTHING IN THE DOCUMENT WAS
BARTOK, HEARSAY AND GARBAGE, DID
YOU TELL ANYBODY?
I GUARANTEE YOU THEY DID BUT
HERE’S WHAT ELSE ARE YOU GOING
TO FIND THIS WEEK I HOPE.
THE CONGRESS GOT SUSPICIOUS
ABOUT THE SUB SOURCE.
WANTED TO KNOW HOW RELIABLE THE
PERSON WAS.
IN 2018, 2018, ASK FOR A
BRIEFING FROM THE FBI ABOUT THE
WASH AND TRICKLE RUSSIAN SUB
SOURCE BECAUSE THE
INTEL COMMITTEES WERE GETTING
SUSPICIOUS AND I FOUND THE
BRIEFING NOTES AND THEY LIED TO
CONGRESS, THE FBI DID, LIKE THEY
LIED TO THE FISA COURT.
WHAT WE HAVE OVER THREE YEAR
PERIOD, 16, 17, AND 18 COME AS
A COMPLETE BREAKDOWN OF THE RULE
OF THE SYSTEM AT EVERY TURN AND
IS JUST NOT A FEW BAD ACTORS
UNFORTUNATELY, IT’S A SYSTEM
FAILURE AND YOU HAVE SALLY YATES
TOMORROW.
YOU’RE PLANNING ON BRINGING IN
COMEY IN THE CABIN AT SOME POINT
STRZOK IN PAGE.
DO WE EVER GET TO THE JULY 5TH
MEETING IN THE OVAL OFFICE WERE
BIDEN TALKED ABOUT THE LOGAN ACT
AND OBAMA TALKED ABOUT GETTING
HIS PEOPLE ON THIS, HIS PEOPLE,
THE RIGHT PEOPLE AND WHEN
SALLY YATES ADMITTED SHE WAS
SHOCKED THAT OBAMA KNEW ALL
ABOUT THE KISLYAK CALL AND COMEY
WAS THERE IN COMEY SAID WE HAD
NOTHING AND THAT WE KNOW
PETER STRZOK SAID WE HAVE
NOTHING WITH ANY EVIDENCE OF
TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION THEN THEY
KNEW IT ALL THEY KEPT GOING
FORWARD WITH THE LIES TO THE
FISA COURT AND THEN THEY WENT
FORWARD WITH THE IMPEACHMENT
INVESTIGATION.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT THEY KNEW
AND WHEN THEY KNEW IT.
ARE THEY ALL GOING TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE, LINDSEY GRAHAM?
>> ALL I CAN TELL YOU IS THAT WE
ARE GOING TO HAVE AN ELECTION IN
2020 AND I HOPE PEOPLE CONSIDER
THE OBAMA JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO
BE WHAT IT WAS.
SALLY YATES WILL TESTIFY BEFORE
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
AUGUST 5TH.
WE WILL HAVE A TALK.
>> Sean: SHE SIGNED ONE OF THE
WARRANTS, DIDN’T SHE?
ONE OF THE APPLICATIONS.
>> IF YOU KNEW THEN WHAT YOU
KNOW NOW WHAT YOU HAVE CITED?
>> Sean: ROD ROSENSTEIN ION
ANSWER THAT QUESTION BEFORE YOUR
COMMITTEE AND HE SAID HE WOULD